hey what's up guys this is Mary at e3
2016 I'm here with Alex from tiny build
games thanks for being thanks for having
me yeah and you're going to show me now
this game caught my eye immediately
because of the concept of it this is a
well what I would consider a
post-apocalyptic train survival game
you're you're the train you're the
conductor yes I am playing as conductor
here and as you can see the world is not
doing too well and I have just arrived
at the station which I need to scavenge
because my train is now locked so I need
to find the code to unlock this train
there's something wrong with the world
here there's there's a something maybe
the infected or something wrong going on
here something is definitely not right
you know we've heard a lot of origin
stories of the apocalypse so we're not
focusing on that right we're just like
okay what would happen if you would have
a train that you drive around and a
world that has gone to hell yeah I love
the concept of this because not only are
you just trying to survive but as the
conductor you're trying that you're on
the move you're actually trying to get
to the next station each time exactly
and along the way aisles oh my god
there's a dude there there is a dude
there along the way I find bodies like I
just found the pistol I'll also be able
to find actual people who are alive and
they're going to join me on the train
however having them with me is going to
post a dilemma of well whether or not I
should spend my resources on giving them
alive can you make those really hard
choices about whether or not you even
want to take survivors um we land so
that you kind of have to take everyone
there is no choice not you have to be a
good person we force you like along the
path of being good but then you realize
that when you have wasted all of your
mat gets fighting these guys right here
then you know you're not doing so well
so what are we gonna do with that guy
he's coming after you so what we can do
is we have a little Millie attack that
we can use but I'm just gonna head shot
him right here nice good to save our
bullets so if you have just one enemy
you really want to not waste a lot of
ammo on him where's your ammo count my
ammo count
at the bottom right here there's also a
few other things people should be aware
of it's like a health bar med kit count
have two met Gus here and I'm looking
for a key right here because your train
is locked um yes my train is locked i'm
looking for a code and then there are
keys that help me unlock specific areas
that are usually that guy in the corner
doesn't look so hot no no i don't think
he's doing too well but i have just
found the code for the actual trailer
lock so let's see if we can make it back
without dying looks like you found some
resources as well i'm carrying a box
which i can actually throw at enemies
again this this game in this game you
will not have a lot of bullets you will
want to strategize and you want to think
ahead like right now oh my god not to
waste bullets and still take down
enemies so I really want to one shot
everyone because the bullets are
extremely valuable like we've been
getting a lot of positive feedback about
it being very difficult and that's
intentional but the trick about making
difficult games is you really need to
make sure the player blames themselves
when they lose right bad play not bad
game mmm exactly so this looks like it
just keeps on going oh god there's a
bunch more you panicked a little bit I
panicked I just wasted way too much ammo
that's not going well you also lost a
little bit of health so when would you
actually use that med kit is like right
when you're about to go I can use my
method right now which I'm going to do
just to demonstrate it but now I have
any one method left and there is a woman
that I have saved on my train and if
she's going to be injured I am NOT gonna
be able to help very much because you're
gonna keep that med kit for yourself
exactly and now I'm just running into a
guy here who is also going to join me
he's pointing a gun at you well you know
we're friendly people we it seems seems
intense it seems like an intense
discussion yeah what but we really want
players to figure out if they want to
prepare for the next station like for
example i'm just going to activate the
train sequence to show you 76 so the
game is split into two parts one is what
we just saw like we're scavenging we're
killing enemies we're trying to stay
alive or rescuing people the other part
is getting to the next station
and the reasons called the final
stations that we're actually going
somewhere we're going there is an ending
to this there is an ending this game is
story driven and part of the story is
figuring out like ok these two guys are
on the train her health is not doing so
well so I'm not gonna help her stuff but
she already used one of those med kits
earlier so she's gonna have to survive I
totally did now if I am to get these
guys to where they're going then they're
going to reward me with valuable things
like for example I will be able to craft
more met kiss other things I think
they're not going to the final station
with you they're going to get off
earlier they're going to the next
inhabited station the way that the game
is structured there are five acts and in
between the acts there are inhabited
stations where you can buy things you
can upgrade your train you can upgrade
your weapons and prepare for what's
coming next after that know how what if
you wanted to replay this game is it the
same every time or are those rooms that
you're going in are those different the
game is built in a linear fashion a lot
of people have asked like if is this
going to be a roguelike over procedural
but we do we want to tell the story and
handcraft each level so you're learning
more about these characters then through
this story how much do they impact the
game they will impact the way that you
played the game so if I let all of these
people die and i'm going to have a hard
time in a couple of stations from now
because I will not have God inserting
the resources and it's all about making
sure that you have all of the tools to
survive so what are you doing right now
it looks like you're doing like upkeep
on the train yes so this train you
there's no no engineers anymore so I got
up keep it and things are going wrong
here like for example my ventilation
system is about to collapse oh he saw
you fix it right here and there we go
then the under is lights that need to be
maintained
right here these are basically kind of
some small mini games to maintain the
trains integrity so you can make it to
the next stage exactly as you can see
over here I have like a couple of
systems that need to be maintained and
then in the menu right here I have a
message from someone who's waiting for
me at the next station there's going to
be like you know ways to chat there is a
crafting system right here so if i have
enough loot i can craft stuff on my way
to the next station but let's just go
ahead and park this train as the next
station to see what kind of other things
we have in store it's not an animation
sequence to show that your docking and
look like those people were also hungry
weren't they yeah they're pretty much
dead now so oh god what normal is he
apocalypse who so is gonna be nice this
has been dark so far but not everyone
can survive the zombie apocalypse or the
infected apocalypse I really think
there's zombies there's something going
on with them up there is something going
on with them but you know we're not
going for the zombie cliche but a lot of
people have described this game like you
know post-apocalypse on a train or
zombies on trade sure that we can goes
up but in ethics core it's a very
methodical game we're like for example
how come that went so fast that's a
different timing inside so there are
different enemy types there is the
center guys at right here I can just
like try to Emily him everyone is super
deadly and then it gets progressively
more difficult so I present but I still
have like normal pistol like I'm gonna
be able to find the shotgun layer in
this level or maybe the next one but the
bullets are gonna be super use your box
sorry bug septa yep
just wasted way too many boys on those
yeah you're down to six bullets so let's
rough I'll but you're you're in a
convenience store yes I am in a
convenience store and there is bad guys
everyone trying to catch them right here
all right so I'm collecting loot right
here and that loot the greens things are
the ones that I can craft so what I can
do here oh there is all guy every of
their I'm just gonna drop this box and
his headless oh that was a good that was
a good idea so you're constantly
probably trying to what are those I just
killed a birth I'm sorry my country's it
for fun for practice or survival I
thought bullets we're really important
to keep yeah yeah they are so we're
probably gonna die in this level I hope
it was worth it to shoot that not
infected very well you know I made you
laugh so that's that's probably worth it
but now oh crap you still got a lot of
help though you'll set it to melee them
to death yeah everything needs to
mailing them I really need to think what
I'm doing here alright so there are two
guys at the bottom over there I'm gonna
try to get this guy and there we go one
bullet do nope one bullet yeah I have
one bullet in stock so that's for toll
let's see if that's gonna be enough to
make it out of here so I'm gonna try to
break this wall oh there was a guy you
found a new guided to not survive well
yeah to go on my trainable the best part
is that when they die on your train you
can actually lose their bodies and get a
little bit off of them my god it kind of
seems like you're not a great dude like
a conductor that's murdering people and
taking their stuff but this is the
apocalypse well you gotta do what you
gotta do it away right ok so I have just
found the code and we can actually keep
on going and let's see if we can get any
of those people too maybe not die did
you find any food like how do you know
what resources you got that can help you
along your way um I'm not sure if I got
any food here but you can see all of
that we can get on the train it seems
like it's actually hard enough free you
yourself to survive let alone these
other people but what kind of items will
they give you if you do keep them alive
and get them to their destination for
example if you help a lot of people in
the beginning then odds are at the first
thing have the station you can get them
an upgrade for your pistol with
something they giving it kind of upgrade
something that makes you faster for
example a laser sight or you know like a
bigger clip or like if you're using a
sawed-off shotgun maybe you'll get
natural shotgun with more shells it like
I wasn't that injured it's misleading
because he's clearly bleeding um but his
health is reasonable so oh no that guy's
super dead lose-lose corpse that's okay
i just told him i got some cigarettes on
some money what are you gonna do with
cigarettes well it's the apocalypse you
know there is no no rules anymore you
can actually smoke old smoke cigarettes
are not gonna help you are they they're
gonna calm down your nerves probably
right i wish will make you more
effective see that gets right here in
food so let's actually see if I can um
move up one of these people there we go
you got your phone you chose her that
other guy's not doing so hot so did you
basically just choose which one you were
gonna save exactly I kind of know that
damn is cold I'm really coming off as
not oh no you lost another ladies go
ahead why did I got you took that dead
guy's pants off well as good pants I
mean there's no Mesa seni more in this
world right so you got signature go take
you you've killed let's see people die
and you've acquired cigarettes and pants
on this journey I hope that that leads
you just some kind of goodness later on
I don't know how pants are gonna help
you how are pants not helpful like you
I've never pants hurting people I guess
it's good to have them try you know have
you ever had the nightmare when you wake
up with no pants in the public place I
did like it's not pleasant this is my
nightmare a conductor with just enough
pants in the cigarettes and one
cigarette to smoke as the world just
blows up around you well it sounds like
an incredibly incredibly difficult but
rewarding game how long is it supposed
to take till you get to your destination
um the game is going to take about five
between five and seven hours but that's
if you make it i mean you're talking
about rounds and rounds to play through
before you get there yeah if you're
playing on hard mode you're going to
have hard time and this game is split up
into five acts where we have made a
public alpha for the first act the
reactions have been incredibly positive
and then we're crunching aiming to
release it in August at PAX Prime August
and what can people find this game on
people will be able to get it on steam
so PC Mac Linux and ps4 and xbox one
alright so that was the final station
thank you so much for showing me that
game Alex thank you for having me and
for everything else games related you're
gonna want to stay tuned to gamespot com
thanks for watching oh my god shooting
fragrance
you